hello everyone I'm back from Germany I
actually considered doing a small intro
in Deutsch but after giving that a try I
realized it was just a terrible idea
every day I woke up in Germany you know
I checked the standings for the tata
steel chess tournament and what do I see
I see onigiri in the first place and I
already thought when I get back home I'm
gonna make a nice video about onigiri
leading the Tata Steel chess tournament
2018 and of course what happens I get
home and a new Giri draws his game and
he is no longer in the lead but it was
nice seeing him in the lead for the
first five rounds here we have a game
between Bhaskar an Audubon and
Shakir Momiji Aarav and it's a it's an
extremely high-level game very
entertaining I didn't think I would do a
video today as I'm really tired but then
I thought again and then I realized it
was best to do at least one chess video
we got we got up at like 4:00 a.m. today
and we we had to we had to go from bat
Biermann to kunafa to catch a train had
to take us to the to the airport and
then all of a sudden the train was just
cancelled we were just standing there
and then some lady from the window just
mumbled something in in which and I
didn't understand that thing she said I
don't think even the locals understood
her but then all of a sudden people
started moving away from the train
station and it seems all the trains for
an offer from what pyramid were
cancelled so we didn't really have any
choice we had to call a taxi and the
ticket I mean the the fare was like a
hundred and seventy euros plus the fifty
years we had to pay for the train ticket
and that's like over 200 euros but it
seems that we will be able to get back
our money since it as it turns out you
can't just cancel a train without
announcing it so that's that's positive
but getting back to the game this is
round six of the Tata Steel chess
tournament we have Bhaskar and Adi bond
with the white pieces and I always say
Adi bond is a very exciting exotic
player if you remember last year in the
Tata Steel chess tournament he played
the Kings gambit with the white pieces
against wisely so he drew that game it
was very exciting
a very nice skirmish
here he has the white pieces against
Shockley Muhammad yarrow so let's see
this game he opens with C for the
English opening and we have a c5 so the
symmetrical variation Knight to f3
knight c6 and d4 see captors Knight
captures and Knight to f6 Knight to c3
g6 we have a three Bishop to c5 and
Bishop to e3 here white has plenty of
options he can push III he can retreat
with the Knight to f3 and maybe even to
b3 to harass the Bishop on c5 Adi one
goes for Bishop to e3 Knight capture son
before Bishop captures on d4 and b6 now
we have E for Bishop to b7 mama D ro
attacks now d4 pawn twice and b4 again
here are the ban had some options of
maybe playing f3 but before is a is it
is a more active way of protecting efore
so b4 and Bishop to e7 if you capture
Bishop captures Queen captures then you
develop whites Queen now the queen is
also protecting me 4 so this is only
helping white so after b4 Bishop to e7
and here Bishop to d3 by Audubon and
this was a very interesting moment in
the game because instead of this Bishop
to d3 it seems like you can push each 5
and what happens if you push e 5 black
has only two squares he can go to he can
go back to GA - this is never a good
idea and he can go to e4 what happens if
94 then Queen g4 Knight captures on c3
and now Queen captures on g7 going for
the rook
after rook to f8 Bishop captures on c3
and it's a very double-edged position of
white it does seems to be a bit better
here but it seems Adi bana was convinced
that mama D ro was prepared to play this
position with black and he didn't want
to go into any complications or
preparation bye-bye mama D Arif so after
Bishop to e7
he plays simply continuous developing a
Bishop to d3 doesn't go for the for the
fancy line d6 we have castles by both
sides and Queen to e2 Knight to d7
rope
f.2d one broke the c8r up the c1 and
queen to c7 both players just developing
pieces and night the b5 and this was my
Medeiros plan when he played Queen to c7
his idea is going to be 8 and then Queen
to 8 creating a battery with this Bishop
on b7 so Queen to b8 we have Queen g4
and Knight to f6 now attacking the Queen
we have Queen back to e2 and here we
have knight back to the 7 and Queen back
to g4 here
Audubon proposes a draw if mama Yara
would continue with Knight to f6
it would leap to threefold repetition
but he goes Knight to e5 he's not
interested in a draw even though he's
playing with the with the black pieces
but there is a significant significant
difference in rating I think mama D ro
is more than 100 trading points above
bhaskar inaudible maybe even 150 points
so Queen to g3 and Knight to g6 we have
f3 rock F to d8 Bishop to f1 Bishop to
h4 kicking away the Queen Queen to g4
and h6 Bishop to e3 now Bishop back to
f6 Knight to d4 and rook to e8 and here
rook to e8 probably but to stop a demon
from any any ideas of maybe sacrificing
denied any six but even if this was the
case it doesn't really work for example
even if black pushed something is weird
as a five-night character simply doesn't
work even if black captures the knight
after Queen captures on e6 the King can
simply move to h8 or 87 and it's it's
all good for black but the problem is
after Knight captures any six black and
simply played in 95 kicking away the
Queen and only then recapturing and then
black will be better
so after night to d4 we did have this
rook here and now Knight back the b5 by
honeyBun probably hoping for mommy I
have to play rook to the 8th again but
he plays the other
Roxy to d8 we have a 4
Bishop to c6 and Queen to g3 now with a
triple attack under the six pawn
Bishop to h4 now forcing the Queen to
move away from g3 queen g4 and rook to
e7 Bishop to d3 we have Bishop to f6 f
for now and here our Iman is slowly but
surely pressing the position Queen to
eight now this battery is created with
Queen and eight and Bishop and c6 with a
double attack on the e4 pawn and we have
rook to e1 would the idea that if Bishop
captures Bishop captures Queen captures
no Bishop capture some b6 now there's an
attack on the Queen and also on the rook
on the eight
so after rook to e1 rook D to D seven
getting the rook out of D 8 and the
bishop to have to know the rook on e 1
is also protecting the e4 pawn with a 5
and this is a this is a good move
allowing a d1 to capture the b6 pawn but
then he has a cat for some before
creating a past be phone be pawn for
himself so Bishop captures a captures
and a5 now but Audubon now has a very
nice past a pawn b3 we have king - h1 +
e5 now we have f5 Knight to f4 and
Bishop to B 1 and here we have d5 and
this is still anyone's game but when
you're playing black and you managed to
push d5 this is move 38 you manage to
push d5 you have to feel a little bit
good about yourself so it captures on d5
and now Bishop captures on b5 a very
interesting choice C capture some b5 and
now Queen captures on d5 and now other
one has these two very nice pass pawns
and plays Bishop to e4 which the idea
that if Queen captures on b5 then Bishop
to c6 and this will attack the Queen and
rook but this actually might have been
Mahmud Arabs best choice for example
Queen captures okay Bishop does come to
c6 but after Queen a6 Bishop captures
rook captures and
Audubon is up the exchange but this past
B point is very dangerous he's already
going to be too
the bishop will be very strong on f6
after black pushes efore the bishop will
also be protecting the pawn on b2 so
probably this was this was better for
black but okay after Bishop to b4 Queen
to d2 and we have a six now now this
past a six bone is also looking very
dangerous me too bye mummy the out of a
rock to b1 and Queen to b4 attacking the
b2 pawn and also protecting the bead
upon and also attacking the b5 pawn so
Bishop to c6 defending with a tempo and
now rook to d3 and now maderos idea is
rook to a3 and by playing rook to a3 he
will be eyeing that a6 pawn to protect
it you know not allow it to move any
further and also the Queen will be I
mean the b5 point but the real idea is
that both the whites rooks will be
forced to stay on first rank because of
rook to a1 and here Bishop to e3 was
played by Audubon and this was this was
the moment where he failed to take some
initiative better was rook to e3 either
forcing him immediate of to exchange or
forcing him to move back but definitely
sorry
definitely not allowing him I'll move
like rook to a3 but okay after rook to
d3 odd/even went for victory III and now
rook to a3 and now this is a this is a
mighty looking position for black a7 and
this is one of mommy dearest plans by
playing rook to a3 now he plays a rope
he captures an a7 given up the exchange
for a rook for a bishop and a pawn
Bishop captures rook captures and Queen
to d1 we have rocked back to a3 and
Bishop to e4 it's a it's very hard to
find a plan here of course that one
doesn't want to give up the b5 point but
what do you play here it's very hard to
come up with a plan if you play
something like Queen to c2 maybe
threatened to win the the b-pawn
you have this Knight to d3 very annoying
going for the rook anyone also defending
the pawn on b2 rook moves and now II for
now this bishop comes alive now the e
pawn is
also marching forward it it's very hard
to find a plan here for a divine
so after up to a three he goes Bishop
three four
mama dr captures the b-pawn Queen
captures Queen to details now going
after the beep on look to be three
defending g3 we have nice to h3 Bishop
to g2 again attacking the knight we have
nice to g5 and now h4 forcing the
Knights to f3 where the bishop will
capture it and after the rook captures
and f3 now rook captures a me too now
Audubon wins the b2 born Queen to a4
rook to e3 and now II for rook to b8
with check King to h7 we have team - G -
Queen - c6 rook captures pawn captures
and King to F 2 and here Bishop to e7 by
momma Dee are off Queen to d3 was played
and if you look at this position a
diamond is up the exchange but mama D ro
has a hesitant Jorah spawn here and it's
very hard very hard again it doesn't
matter we're up the exchange your king
is wide open here on f2 and it's a it's
never Pleasant to play this Bishop to c5
check King to f1 and here comes the
brilliant move by Mahmoud er of Bishop
to a7 moving the bishop so the Queen can
come to c5 to create this very powerful
battery also this comes with a temple on
under rockin b8 so what do you do
rook to be one was played and here Queen
to c5 and here why doesn't that even
push f6 that's the question well this in
fact would would have been the best move
but he decides not to do it there's no
immediate threat here but after f6 and
g6 you do have this weakness of the f7
pawn so maybe this would give a demon
some more chances but okay after Queen
c5 he immediately played King to e1 we
have Queen to have to check King to d1
and now f6 not allowing white na f6
ideas and here rook to b3
it's very interesting
I mean Audubon would be very happy if he
could draw this game unfortunately there
are no rope to be seven ideas you know
with some plans of sacrificing with the
rope and g7 and then going for a
perpetual which with the Queen because
simply Queen captures on g3 now
defending the g7 point and if you
capture the bishop didn't Queen g1 check
and this picks up the rook and a7
so after f6 rook to b3 by a demon queen
g1 check King c2 Queen G to check in c3
and out we can capture in g3 better to
grab a couple of more pawns h5 we have
Queen to e5 check King before Queen to
f4 check King b5 and now F to the thread
is spawn to f1 promoting to a queen of
course Rock to be one between g4 you
know why not roof to a-1 attacking the
bishop bishop to d4 now attacking the
rook rook F 1 and now Queen to G to the
ideas of course if Queen captures Bishop
Queen captures rook on f1 with check so
King c4 now Bishop here King goes for
the Bishop Bishop to e3 now King a4 and
now Bishop to d2 again the Queen can't
capture it because the rook is hanging
on f1 and the thread is division will
eventually come to e1 so King b5 Bishop
to e1 now now the rock is strapped King
to c5 and Queen to g4 attacking
attacking the pawns here are Queen
captures on h5 grabbing another pawn
king to e7 we have Queen to h2 Queen to
d8 and now Queen to h3 attacking the
rook and here we have a final final you
know
strike of resistance by Adam and he
plays Queen to c8 he's hoping for from a
madero to capture the rook on f1 it's a
very interesting if he captures then
King to f7 and black is actually lost
there is no defense against Queen -
Queen to g7 if you try something like h5
simply Queen check King h6 and then
Queen captures and g7 this would have
been checkmate so after Queen to c8
Mahmud are of course isn't gonna fall
for this Bishop to b4
King has to move and now in this
position it's actually perfectly fine to
capture the rook because now the king is
totally in the way but he doesn't even
go for this Queen h5 check King goes to
d8 now Queen to e2 attacking the rook
Quinta c1 defending it and now simply
Bishop to e1 and it was in this position
that the mascara not even resided the
game and shock there mama D ro took the
lead after round six in the Tata Steel
chess tournament the idea is black is
attacking white rook white doesn't
really have anything if you try
something like rook to h1 there's
actually a very simple win
Queen to b4 attacking the rook if you if
you move the rock anywhere on the edge
there and the H file simply you promote
the pawn to Queen if you move back Rock
f1 then Queen d3 checking the King this
picks up the rook and there aren't even
any tricks here for example I have to
route to h1 if maybe Audubon would be
hoping for a promotion then there are no
tricks with rook captures on h6 because
simply pawn captures and then after
Queen to c7 check there are no ideas
here for a perpetual check that after
King moves the white king is in the way
so yeah after this Bishop do you want
move Bhaskaran addabani resigned the
game and shocked her mama tiara is now
in the lead with four and a half out of
six points after round six
so no no lead after round six four on
each giri unfortunately so yeah that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank Henry made Gregory
Finlay Theory picked out mutate music
Luis Molina Victor Fuentes ahmed el
nazar and Jason Lucas for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it
thank you all for supporting me on my
new Instagram and twitch channel I
really appreciate that as well I like I
said I will start streaming on Twitch
probably I will try to set it up
tomorrow but if I I won't be able to
make it then next week surely and I
still owe you that
subscribers video with your photos and
videos I haven't forgotten about that I
will get
that as well people have been actually
received a lot more of the material
after New Year's so it's a it's better
better better to wait you know for
people to send more so yeah like I said
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
still it'll still take me a while to to
get back to making chess videos it was a
very relaxing week in Germany as usual
of course you can check two of my
previous videos here thank y'all for
watching and I will see you soon